challenge but important everyone should
be able to visit work schools a go-to
museum even with mobility constraints
to stimulate cities to not only comply
with european standards but also to
learn from each other
and to award the front-runners the
european commission grants an award
to standards that really stand out in
accessibility
at this location the eurovision 2020 was
supposed to be held
and it was supposed to be a very
accessible event
but then the pandemic struck and instead
of a venue for a big party and a
celebration of inclusion
it became an emergency hospital in this
pandemic public life
have come to a standstill however the
need for inclusion did not
government information health facilities
and what is left of the fun things
everybody has a right to be included
more than ever this price is important
let's find out who the winner is of the
x's cbo
2021 yeah let's put in our masks keep
our distance
[Music]
so nick you do a lot with accessibility
of cities what do you do
well since my spine injury in 2010 i
raise awareness for people with
disability in the netherlands and abroad
so if you're blind
or if you're there for in a wheelchair
like me i help
companies or cities to adapt
for people with disabilities i walk
around the city i see
public transport is is accessible
streets are accessible
we're pretty far or is there still a lot
of obstacles you can't get over
it's always kind of a difficult question
because when i
put you in a wheelchair you will see
that the world isn't
that accessible as we think we are and
then
this spring the pandemic hit how has it
affected people with disabilities
well what i uh what i read about as well
is that public transport has been
become more difficult for example if
you're in a wheelchair somebody has to
push you into a train which is kind of
one and a half two meter distance a
difficult thing uh for people that are
deaf it's difficult to talk to people
when you can't see their
mouth at the moment yeah uh uh which way
of an example
they make it easier for people where
they can't
we have to read lips or difficulties
recognizing emotions
they can also see better yeah which is a
brilliant brilliant example actually
and the second thing is the digital
accessibility as well so imagine if
you're
if you can't see everything or you're
blind and nowadays you work at home
so you're behind the internet the whole
day so accessible
accessibility in websites shops or
municipalities is a big thing as well
let's get started different people
involved in this prize will announce the
three winners
and we will hear their reactions we also
have two special mentions one for city
that sees accessibility
not only as means for inclusion of
people
with disability but as an opportunity to
make the city better for everybody
and a special mention for a city that
did outstanding work in making
the physical theory accessible and a
special
one-time owning award for a city with an
outstanding crisis management response
and digitalization to make sure
information and facilities for covid
are accessible to everyone the special
mention for accessibility of public
services
in time of the pandemic and if you watch
this video on social media subtitles and
international sign translation are
included
and if you watch this on the conference
platform kudo we also have translation
to french
italian german spanish and polish as
well as audio description
for the last 10 years the eu has
recognized cities
that are doing their best to offer equal
access to city life for persons with
disabilities
and older people its success and the
growing interest
around the access city award over the
past few years has led us now
to the 11th edition of the award
over 11 years there have been 425
applicants and 68 rewarded cities
this year 50 applications were received
for the access city awards 2021
and as announced by commissioner for
quality helena dally
six prizes will be awarded one overall
winner
two runners-up and three winners in
special mention categories
a novelty for this very special year is
that there is one special mention
category on accessibility in times of
pandemic
this year the six shortlisted cities in
alphabetical order are bremerhaven
germany ferente italy gidenia
poland yonsho pink sweden cometini
greece and poznan poland
the six winners of the access city award
2021
will join their predecessors in becoming
symbols of commitment
innovation and progress towards creating
genuinely accessible cities
and serve as an inspiration to others
across the eu
and beyond good luck to all
the access city rewards recognizes and
celebrates as a city willingness
ability and efforts to become more
accessible in order to guarantee
equal access to fundamental rights
improve the quality of life of its
population and ensure that everyone
regardless of age
mobility or ability has the equal access
to the resources and pleasures cities
have to offer
every european city that believes that
they should win this award could
nominate themselves
50 did so national juries looked at
their applications
and 21 were selected and sent to the
european jury
and they then selected six finalists and
choose the winners from those six
and the winning city will get an
astonishing 150 000 euro
last year the winner of the tent award
was warso what did they do in the last
10 years to earn that award
our reporter went to see but not here
welcome to the accessible city of warsaw
we've worked hard over the last 10 years
to adopt inclusive approaches
and integrate our communities
[Music]
we recently won the access city award
2020
for commitment to promoting
accessibility for all
today we're going to speak to the city's
residents to see how they've benefited
from the changes
[Music]
in 2017 the city legislated to ensure
new infrastructure complies with
accessibility standards
have you noticed the changes
warsaw has come a long way to eliminate
architectural barriers
facilities such as driveways and lifts
have been introduced to help people with
disabilities in their daily lives
[Music]
our transportation system has undergone
changes
upgrading bus stops and implementing
accessible vehicles
and roaring stocks is it easier for you
to
access the whole city now
yes it is getting better many trams and
buses are equipped with the system
to redelight the names of the stops many
curbs of pedestrian crossings
have been lowered and equipped with the
tension pulse some pedestrian bottoms
now play sounds now it is much easier
for us to move around
and it is safer
at present i am pleased that all these
buses and trams are being adapted for
persons with disabilities
especially
perhaps the most important thing for me
is that the vehicle should have a low
floor
then i feel safe and i can manage
and it didn't used to be that way the
warsaw metro is also very admirably
adapted for people in wheelchairs
[Music]
how have the changes affected your
ability to
travel away from or so
when it comes to traveling the train
stations are really important
they are more and more accessible at all
the main train stations in warsaw
there are tactile markings on the floor
there are guiding paths
there are points of attention at some
stations there are also tactile
how is the city insured it's inclusive
[Music]
i see that museums in the city of warsaw
are aware of the needs of the deaf for
example
lectures guided tours discussions about
exhibits
when the deck want an interpreter an
interpreter is available
there are also deaf guides who guide the
museums themselves
thanks to this the participants learn
more and more information
for me this is a good positive future
removing barriers and culture
is also a story about warsaw this can be
felt most strongly during the culture
without barriers festival
warsaw has been funded continuously for
eight years film festivals
theatrical speculations exhibitions and
museums
and galleries or even walks around the
city are always held
all this is for people with disabilities
those who cannot see
those who cannot hear those in
wheelchairs are on the spectrum
this is our celebration of accessible
culture
have you used the city's websites to get
information
communication and navigation have become
easier with the warsaw website and
mobile applications
the city's accessible website makes it
easier for us to find important
information
[Music]
you work for the city don't you
ever been working in the museum for two
years as an accessibility coordinator
i think it's very important for this
position and what we do in the museum
that i am a person with a disability
through our activities we meet the
specific needs of different people
with different disabilities we have for
example
programs such as the morning birds
program for people with autism
where only these people have access to
the museum and their sensory stimulus
are limited or for example the sensory
friendly concert event
where children can access the mute room
or the muting headphones
this enables them to stay at the concert
for as long as possible
for people with intellectual and
development disabilities we organize
family and educational events for
special schools
blind people can benefit from typograph
and audio description
deaf people can use sign language
translation
the opinion of those interested is also
very important to us
we listen to what they say and try to
prepare subsequent events
as well
[Music]
m
warsaw is a city that takes
accessibility for all series
it still has work to do but for now its
efforts are being rightly recognized
and its citizens and visitors are
enjoying city life to the fullest
we will continue to work hard to break
down barriers
[Music]
when you talk about accessibility we
think the nordic countries are the
western european ones but we see
central european countries doing
remarkably well is accessibility now i
think
throughout europe yeah absolutely and
it's amazing to see that they're
optimizing their accessibility
so good well that's good to hear well
here to react is the mayor of warsaw
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
well let's start handing out awards
we're going to start with a special
mention
for in these times of pandemic and we
just discussed the needs of people with
disabilities have drastically changed
some are bigger some are smaller
as a municipality how do you know what
to do well the first thing to realize i
think is that
everyone has a handicap you can just see
mine a bit better
so if you want to work on an inclusive
society if we want to work on
accessibility is that to realize that in
these times of epidemic
my needs are for example in a stall
are a big higher at the moment for
example if somebody has autism
you need to think about keeping it
distant for somebody that is
deaf or blind it's difficult to keep the
distance so
in order to get an inclusive society we
need to realize that the needs of people
with disabilities
changed well there was one city in
europe that really stood out in
these times so here to announce the
winner of the special mansion and to
give a sneak preview
of the upcoming strategy and policies to
be implemented in the next 10 years
is the first ever commission of equality
and it's also her first award show
here is the european commission of
equality with helena dali
good afternoon good afternoon everyone
i am pleased and honored to take part in
the first
access city awards ceremony of this
commission's mandate
accessibility is a prerequisite to the
participation
of persons with disabilities on an equal
basis with
others in society more accessible cities
are cities where persons with
disabilities can
enjoy autonomy and spontaneity
accessible cities make getting to school
getting to work
living independently and meeting friends
possible
accessible cities are cities where
services and programs can be
used by all and where participation is
inclusive
this is because accessibility is an
enabler
without accessibility persons with
disabilities
cannot engage meaningfully in their
community
society should be accessible by default
in our daily lives we should not be
asking ourselves about the accessibility
of
cities sport facilities or nature trails
we are working to achieve an eu that is
fair for all
without excluding anyone accessibility
is important for
all of us the european population is
growing
older sooner or later in life
every one of us will need an accessible
environment
accessibility is a plus for everyone
i will ensure that this crucial subject
remains at the forefront
of our actions accessibility is a broad
topic it is not only about the built
environment
it is also about services and products
and transportation accessibility is
essential to guarantee
access to information be it on digital
platforms or through traditional means
like books and we mustn't forget the
importance of
assistive technologies my services are
working with member states to achieve a
rapid and
correct transposition of the european
accessibility act
and i hope that we will continue to work
together in the years to come
for a more accessible society
i know that the future strategy on the
rights of persons
with disabilities which forms part of
the union of equality
is one of the points to be discussed at
the european day
of persons with disabilities conference
we are preparing this new strategy based
on the feedback we received
during the evaluation of the current
disability
strategy during the consultations we
organized over the last few months
the new strategy will cover the period
2021
2030 and it will be our main instrument
at european level
on the rights of persons with
disabilities and i wanted
to bring a positive change of course it
will take
into account the eu's commitments under
the united nations convention
on the rights of persons with
disabilities it will consider relevant
eu legislation
and the european pillar of social rights
i want the strategy to become the
european reference
for all persons with disabilities in
europe
but also for european and national
lawmakers
our new and enhanced strategy will
contribute to the transition
towards a more sustainable innovative
digitalized and fair union a union that
ensures a decent standard of living for
all
a union that leaves no one behind this
is why the strategy
on the rights of persons with
disabilities must be
ambitious the eu is also addressing the
economic
and social consequences of the covet 19
pandemic
and its recovery these measures will
also contribute to building a union of
equality
eu member states and their cities are
affected by the pandemic
i can only say that i am very impressed
when i see
the effort and strength demonstrated in
this crisis
despite the difficult context many
cities
have been and remain shining examples of
how to be truly accessible despite the
current situation
50 cities applied this shows the
determination
and the interest of eu cities to keep on
working on accessibility
no matter what i thank all the
applicants and
congratulate you for your dedication to
accessibility
a big well done to the six cities that
were shortlisted
no matter your ranking you are all
winners and you will become members of
the access city award
network now let's start with what you
are all waiting for
it's the time to announce the winners of
the access city award 2021.
i have in this envelope the name of the
winner of this year's special prize
the prize for accessibility of public
services in times of pandemic
as you know we have six shortlisted
cities in alphabetical order they are
bremerhaven germany florence italy
gdynia poland yonshopping sweden
comotini greece and poznan poland
i know the jurors have been extremely
impressed by all
the applications notably for this
special category
however one city really stands out the
winner of this year's special prize
for accessibility of public services in
times of pandemic
is
poznan congratulations poznan
it was inspiring to see that you
provided daily information in sign
language
i also appreciate the launch of the
telephone of cordiality
you deserve this award as you are truly
an example when it comes to
accessibility for everyone in the eu
special mention for accessibility of
public services
in times of pandemic poznan poland
poznan the fifth most populated city in
poland
has worked hard in recent years to make
itself a more inclusive place for
everyone
in particular the city has shown a
strong commitment to improving its
public services during the course of the
recent global
the cousins specifically targeted those
in high-risk groups
and launched several strong initiatives
to support them during this difficult
time
a service was set up for persons with
disabilities and older people
where volunteers will go shopping for
food and hygiene products
as well as medicines and deliver these
safety to their doors
a telephone helpline was also set up but
older people living alone
could call the sibley talk to municipal
volunteer
this helpline ensures those in isolation
are maintaining social contact
and their overall health and condition
are being monitored
[Music]
the city also launched a digital advice
service aimed at teaching older people
how to use technology this service
allowed them to keep in touch with loved
ones
and to use certain online services ict
consultants
explained how to send emails download
photographs
visit websites on how to install
applications on their devices
information on the pandemic was provided
daily in sign language
thanks to these efforts and in order to
highlight its incredible work during
this difficult time
this year koznin wins a special mention
for accessibility of its public services
in times of pandemic
wow congratulations poznan here to react
is their mayor
thank you for this honor from the very
beginning of the pandemic
we knew that we had to support residents
of our city
particular attention was paid to seniors
and people with disabilities
that is those classified as high-risk
groups
we wanted them to be able to use public
services meeting
their everyday needs with all safety
precautions
preserved therefore we launched
the digital advice hotline to help
seniors
use new technologies we provided
advice taught seniors how to install
software
send emails or upload photos
aspect important for us was activation
for the elder
the isolation was extremely difficult
especially for single people
that is why we started the mask of
senior action
during which seniors were serving mass
face masks
for their peers then this
face masks were distributed by
volunteers free of charge
we also provided for a special helpline
the cordiality phone for seniors from
postman to call and talk about
their concerns our volunteers
helped with shopping for seniors and for
people with disabilities
buying basic products for them in order
to protect them
as much as possible from the necessity
to go out the service was free of charge
but beneficiaries
had to pay for their purchases
all these services originally developed
by the city of bosnia
were prepared after an analysis of the
local needs of seniors and people with
disabilities
most of them is still available well
let's move to our second special mansion
this city demonstrates accessibility as
a business model and an opportunity and
particularly
good accessibility attracts tourism
which is important for the region
and its economy the applicant approached
accessibility holistically
and embraced it as an opportunity to
really improve the whole city so this
award is handed out by the european
disability forum
they speak and work for all people with
disabilities in europe
as a european umbrella organization edf
is the link between persons with a
disability
and the eu institution the edf makes
sure that disabled people are not
forgotten
when new laws are written for all
european countries after all the motto
of the disability movement
is nothing about us without us here to
announce a special mention
accessibility as an opportunity for the
whole city is the edf
president dear commissioner
ladies and gentlemen this year
we celebrate the accessibility
in very unusual circumstances
due to the covet 19 pandemic
in these circumstances millions of
europeans
are experiencing limitations
in their daily lives in their human
contacts
in their freedom of movement in all
aspects
of their lives but this is what
we have been saying for many years
this is why we have been advocating
for accessibility these situations
are the daily life of persons with
disabilities
we have seen the last decade very
important developments
this award the european accessibility
act
the very recently approved european
accessibility standard
of build environment
this award this year takes place
in unusual situations as you have said
the cities around the union experience
many problems in providing accessibility
to their citizens
to very important services to healthcare
transport commerce important information
in all domains
it is my pleasure and my honor
to present the special mention
to the city that has adopted
the motto accessibility
as an opportunity for the whole city
the name of the city is
[Music]
greece congratulations commodity
special mention for accessibility as an
opportunity
for the whole city camatini greece
cometini's modern urban center surrounds
the medieval fortress
making accessibility a challenge in
spite of this
unlimited financial resources cometini
has made significant improvements
and shown great commitment to becoming
accessible to achieve this
the city devised a multi-phase
development program for accessibility
and social inclusion which funded
certain initiatives in the city
the urban infrastructure was improved
with the inclusion of bicycle lanes
accessible open spaces and public
buildings
social initiatives such as the creation
of a community and activity centre run
for
and by persons with disabilities as well
as after school programs
for children with intellectual
disabilities were co-funded by the city
and run by local civil society
organizations
thanks to this development program 20
kilometers of walkways in the city are
now accessible
90 of schools and 75 of public buildings
have also improved their accessibility
measures with 47 out of 60 playgrounds
also being accessible
[Music]
cometini has strived to cover all
aspects of life from the accessibility
of sport facilities
to the improvement of the local bus
network to improve the quality of life
for everyone as a result of this
holistic approach
cometini was a special mention for its
inclusive approach
to improving accessibility in the city
to better the lives of all
really thank you thank you mr
rolacastandis
it's a great honor to be awarded by you
for
access city awards 2020
i'm spiritual athenaeus i represent uh
komotini it's municipality every
disabled person
had non-disabled academics
as a community uh we are all uh
being uh really proud we are
really proud for this award uh komotini
is one of the friendliest
towns uh in europe and in greece
for disabled persons probably not one of
the most accessible but
we are sure we are one of the
friendliest because
we fight for that as a community side by
side
organizations i'm a member of both of
an association called perpato
there is also from this and many many
others but
also municipality all the local
authorities
and we all work for that uh as a whole
it's true that uh we actually
took accessibility as an opportunity for
the whole city
uh kozuko motini is a city of multiple
colors cultures and uh people
who who know we who cannot
accept that uh they can be discriminated
we need a city which is very free
discrimination
free and can be a city for everybody
with no exceptions and no
barriers we fought for that awards
the last 20 years we played
a lot of systems lots of strategies
we competed with other cities
i'd like to give my gratitude to the
committee
to the people of our municipality to the
people who work for that
to build people who work for the awards
and
send the application and also to the
other cities and
every other disabled person who works
for
his or her town or their town and
try to make it better the truth is that
it's not
only a municipality effort but it's all
about the disabled people
creating the world for us
and buy us nothing for us without us
uh please uh keep trying uh your best
for your city
congratulations again como tini we're
gonna go to the last special mansion for
the build environment
and when we build something new of
course we make it accessible
but what about historic buildings museum
archaeological sites
should they also be accessible for
people in a wheelchair i think
one thing we do need to accept that we
can't adapt the whole world we can't
make the whole world accessible
the most important thing is that i know
what is accessible
and what is not so if we go to an
historic
site scene for example we just can't
make it accessible but if i know it
beforehand
it's not a problem because i can choose
to take another path but and one thing
that's really important in the build
environment is that
everything is done so basically from
when you leave your house to when you
arrive
it needs to be adapted if there's one
hindrance the whole thing doesn't make
sense anymore
how do you adapt to that as a city well
the difficult thing for example with
a guided path for people that are blind
uh 58 percent of all the parts in the
netherlands are obstructed
so you walk from your house you go to a
museum for example and then the parts is
abstracted so
to look at the broad perspective as a
municipality or as a city
that's i think the key issue to make
everything accessible and that the
people know
what is accessible and what's not well
one city really stood out in making a
build environment accessible
here to announce the winner is the
president of the european jury
shadi abu zara
i must say it has been an incredible
pleasure and honor
to serve as the chair of the eu jury
i've had the pleasure of working with a
whole group of very insightful judges
with very diverse expertise in different
areas
we went through many applications that
this year came in from
all around europe many different cities
and countries have applied this year and
this was a real pleasure
to look at all these applications and to
try to find commonalities between them
just a reminder that we're not awarding
the most accessible cities
this would be a very different type of
award
what we're really looking for is the
holistic approach
to accessibility how the cities address
many different aspects given their
particular context and backgrounds
some cities are big others are smaller
some have particular geographic contexts
and others have very different
economical contexts as well
so we consider all these aspects and we
try to look at how
these cities address the inclusive
aspect of accessibility how they combine
many different things
how they address people with
disabilities including older people
which are age-related related
impairments as well as maybe children
and the education aspects so
there's really a lot to look at for
example the built environment
transportation and also digitization
technologies how cities use technology
to provide accessibility and this year
in particular
we have been looking at the response to
the kovid 19 pandemic
which has impacted us all
so looking at all these different
aspects we really try to look at
how cities demonstrate progress
on each of these aspects and how they
as a whole address accessibility and
disability
this special mention this year is on
built environment
to me this means that the city that one
has shown extraordinary progress in
a very particular area in the built
environment
in ensuring physical access to people
with different kinds of disabilities
so without a do
let's take a look i have an envelope
here
stating the city
so the city with
the winner for the built environment
the special mention of built environment
this year is
florence congratulations florence
all the best and keep up the good work
special mention for the built
environment ferensei
italy ferensei
is without a date one of the most
popular tourist destinations in europe
with its narrow streets and ancient
renaissance buildings
however this great culture heritage also
creates challenges
with regard to accessibility the massive
presence of cultural heritage buildings
makes accessibility interventions
essential
but they are also tough to implement at
the same time
to this end firence launched a plan to
improve the accessibility of its
buildings
public spaces and infrastructure across
the city
buses and trams as well as stations in
old narrow streets are now accessible
making the historical centre accessible
to all and helping persons with
disabilities get around easily
all taxis are now able to transport
wheelchairs and across the city
parking spaces for persons with
disabilities have been built
as a result of this plan firenze now has
the highest number of parking spaces for
persons with disabilities in italy and
renovations were carried out to enhance
equal access
to 29 public facilities such as schools
sports centres museums and libraries
on top of this tours and visits to the
main touristic
and cultural hotspots are now tailored
to include sign language
virtual tours and multi-sensory visits
for its improvement to the built
environment while remaining committed
to its historic and cultural heritage
ferensei
wins a special mention
[Music]
there mr shady about zara
it's a great honor for us to receive
this prestigious recognition
of the commitment of our municipalities
for the disadvantaged citizen
and tourists florence being a world
heritage cities
has always failed the need to grant the
accessibility to everybody
and to allow the visit of its famous
monuments and other kind of facilities
as an ancient city with historical
eurobank of education
it was not easy to fulfill our wishes
for a total to accomplish our mission
we have followed an holistic approach to
ensure a coordinated policies
for a widespread accessibility the
one-stop
shop is meant to provide information on
services
to people with disabilities during the
years we always kept on working
on facilitating that chest to our
museums
as well as our schools offices
rubbling transportation sport fatilises
and to include all kinds of minorities
in the decision-making process in order
to be
able to represent everybody's needs and
to find
the right solution one important step
was taking creating a city council for
people with disabilities
as well as a working group for the
removal of architectural barriers
to suggest interventions and solutions
lots of efforts were also spent on
education and the promotion
of an inclusive approach for those who
could have different needs
and we must all feel obliged to improve
their quality of life guaranteeing an
easy and comfortable
access to all services the municipality
offers
we also created a mobile application
giving real-time information about road
paths
for wheelchairs and create dedicating
painting parking lots for cars of
disabled drivers
the pandemic that is eating our city as
well as the rest of the world
has made our job more challenging today
accessibility to public spaces is now
limited for everybody
due to social distancing but we have
been able to increase the number of
services we can provide
and that includes food and services home
delivery
for fragile and disabled citizens as
well
as remote learning and medical
assistance
we are very satisfied for what we have
done so far
and we are really honored to receive
your appreciation
thank you again for the special mention
for build
environment congratulations again
florence
uh we're gonna now move to the the three
winners uh nick it must be
a hell of a job if you're in the jury to
it's comparing apples and oranges
i'm so glad that i'm not in jury because
it was an incredibly hard house
yeah i'm glad i'm not in their shoes
either but here to announce the third
place is the director for social affairs
of dg
employment social affairs and inclusion
ms ivankovic
knees good afternoon commissioner
good afternoon everyone good afternoon
nick what today i cannot wait for the
commissioner dally to announce the
winner of the access city war 2021
as for me this is the first time i take
part in the accessity awards ceremony
i have to say i feel honored and
privileged as a director for social
affairs at dg employment social policy
and inclusion
jorge ranik i have to say i'm pleased to
see
you are wearing these transparent masks
it is indeed
very important to show them as much as
possible as they are very useful
i also had mine ready in case i would
have been with someone today
however the rules are quite strict in
brussels
and it was better for me to address the
audience alone
believe me i would have preferred to
share the office
and actually the screen with my director
general jose corte
who you will see a bit later i take the
opportunity
to thank my team and our contractor
who have been working very hard in the
past few months
to ensure the smooth organization of the
competition
and today's ceremony as mentioned
by commissioner dali we are pleased by
outcome as 50 cities have indeed applied
this year
it is more than last year and more than
the year before
accessibility is important and this
shows
that everyone is willing to invest more
and more
in becoming more accessible and
inclusive
congratulations to all participants and
to all shortlisted cities
congratulations to poznan florence and
komotini
for their well-deserved awards let us
start
now with the top three of this year's
competition
the third place winning city is
already a member of the access city
award network
indeed this city has been rewarded
already a special mention a few years
ago
it is now rewarded for its strong
commitment to accessibility
and for its continuous improvements the
third
place winner of the axis city award 2021
is
[Music]
the city of gadina in poland
congratulations godina
third prize gidenia poland gidenia's
location
a poor city located on the baltic sea
and part of the tri-city together with
gadansk and sopot
and its large industrial areas make
accessibility a challenge
however its commitment to accessibility
is evident
by its previous access city award win
and continuous improvements over the
years
[Music]
gdynia is now more accessible than ever
before
since 1999 gadinya has consistently been
implementing a social policy
that considers the needs of all of its
residents
over the years an office for persons
with disabilities
has been settled an accessibility expert
appointed
and a council for children with
disabilities established
guidelines for the design and
development of public spaces were also
created
based on the principles of universal
design ensuring accessibility
to facilities and spaces for all
all designs are reviewed by the
accessibility expert
on top of this a center for the rental
of equipment such as crutches
wheelchairs and bicycles was opened
a park was also opened which includes
gym equipment tailored for older people
and persons with disabilities on public
transport
all buses are now equipped with floors
that can be lowered
passenger information boards are now
voice activated and a tactile
paving system has been installed at the
bus stops
for its broad vision universal design
and high level of commitment to
accessibility
gadinya once again wins third prize in
access city award
2021.
ladies and gentlemen first of all i
would like to thank the jury on behalf
of inhabitants of gdynia
for awarding us the third prize in this
year's edition
of access city award it is the people
living in
dania who every day create the unique
atmosphere of our city
a city of openness and sensitivity
to needs of others this is achieved by
means of social campaigns
especially those addressed to children
competition publications that
aim at the rising of social awareness
setting
modern standard of preceding everyone as
equal partners in
all areas of life so that we can live
together
not just next to one another for many
years we have been creating a city
accessible to all
promoting universal design so
that no barriers limit the realization
of
dreams and life full of joy
but most importantly so
that everyone has the right to choose
how they want to life i'm very proud
that
dania is receiving the access city award
for the third time
the road is not easy but as the
ancient saying goes
it is an honor to be included
in such a group thank you very much
congratulations again and here to
announce the second place is the
director general
of the dg employment social affairs and
inclusion mr
yost quarter
good afternoon commissioner ladies and
gentlemen good afternoon
for nick congratulations to godinya
for the third place and to all the
special mentions
despite the difficulties we're all going
through in 2020
this edition of the access city award is
a success
it shows the strong commitment of cities
across the european union
and this gives us hope for a brighter
future
katarina i would like to tell you that i
would have loved to share my office and
screen with you
but as you have pointed out this is
unfortunately not possible
now let's hope for a face-to-face
edition of the access city award
and of the european day of persons with
disabilities next year in 2021
as mentioned during this morning the
opening day of the
person with disabilities accessibility
has been a very important topic
for the past 10 years and as was also
mentioned by the commissioner
it will of course remain an important
one accessibility is
absolutely essential to ensure
participation in society
on an equal basis for everyone and we
spoke a lot about the european
accessibility act
we should also remember that the access
city award was created a decade ago
and that it's one of our best
instruments to raise awareness
on accessibility in the european union
and beyond
i heard indeed that several winning
cities have been contacted
by cities from around the world and by
winning the award
the city becomes a clear example for
everyone
this is now the 11th edition and its
success shows that it's meant to last
finally now i have the honor to announce
you which city is the winner
of the second place of the access city
award 2021
can now open the envelope
the second place winner of the access
city award 2021
is a city which has a comprehensive
approach
and which addresses all kinds of
accessibility issues
for instance it has worked a lot to make
its website accessible by providing
easy to read and read aloud functions
another example is that the main public
passenger ships are accessible for
wheelchair
users you now have a hint this city has
a port
the second place winning city of the
access city award 2021
is bremerhaven in germany
second prize bremerhaven germany
[Music]
bremerhaven is one of the largest cities
in germany
that is located on the north sea coast
[Music]
its porsche beach and unique touristic
attractions such as historic ships
present accessibility challenges for the
city
however the city's education and
commitment
has led to the creation of a
comprehensive approach that addresses
all kinds of accessibility issues
the city's harbour worlds project has
created barrier-free solutions
to areas such as outdoor markets green
spaces
the port and the beach cobblestones were
sanded down to create a flat surface
suitable for wheelchair users people
with walkers prams
and bicycles and ramps added where
possible
when it comes to public transport
seventy percent of bus stops in the city
offer tactile guidance systems
and the main public passenger ships are
now accessible for wheelchairs and other
mobility devices
bremerhaven has also ensured that all
online information on its website
is available in easy to read language
and that there are videos with sign
language
and a read aloud function where possible
the city's disability ombudsman has also
become a permanent contact
for all matters relating to
accessibility and provides advice on
issues relating to participation
rehabilitation and inclusion
[Music]
he also advises on how to make buildings
barrier-free
for its progress across a wide spectrum
of city life
and its comprehensive approach towards
accessibility bremerhaven
wins the second prize in access city
awards 2021.
[Music]
you haven't read my half an hour
[Music]
again congratulations nick it's time to
announce the winner
are you impressed with what you've seen
so far i'm absolutely impressed with
everything that i've seen so
far and it's my biggest dream in a
couple of years to go on holiday with my
three little kids and my wife and i
don't have to think about where we go
anymore because
everything is accessible in europe will
there be a time when this award is no
longer needed
when inclusion is so obvious we don't
even have to award it
let's hope so i think it's always going
to be an topic i mean technology is
going to help us a bit further for the
coming years but it's always going to be
a topic for the next 10
20 years but as long as we have
attention forward as long as we're
paying detail to it
we're gonna be there okay well let's see
who is this year's winner
of the number one award here to announce
it is once again european commissioner
for equality
miss daly good afternoon again
we are now back in the berlin building
and i am
very pleased to announce the name of the
winning city
of this access city award 2021
even though this may no longer be a
surprise for you
but before officially announcing the
winning city
and the reasons why it has been
distinguished i
congratulate bremerhaven florence gdenia
and komotini and you are all leading by
example
and you are now members of the access
city award network
i hope to see you as proactive as the
previous winners
the network is a good way for you to put
forward your ideas
and projects on accessibility this way
you can work together towards becoming
an always more inclusive city now i
think you've all guessed the name in
this
envelope it is with great pleasure that
i announce
john shopping as winner of the xs city
award
2021 access city award
2021 winner john shopping
sweden situated on the shore of a lake
yon shopping's geographical location
make it a beautiful place to live
however its picturesque terrain and
location
have made accessibility a challenge
despite this
jan shopping has shown great dedication
to its growing city
and has prioritized accessibility for
all in both new and old areas of the
city
thanks to its continuous effort and
collaboration with various disability
organizations
to improve the accessibility of public
buildings and infrastructures
yawn shop inc has seen positive results
cultural buildings such as the library
and concert hall
now include tactile maps and signage
audio description
easy to read facilities and wheelchair
access
120 public playgrounds have been
renovated
to improve accessibility with two of the
largest playground
now fully accessible
when it comes to constructing new
buildings yawn shopping
consults its citizens through dialogues
to make sure their accessibility needs
are being met
key players such as disability
organizations are involved from the
beginning of a project
they're involved in the decision making
process
yawn shopping therefore ensures that all
groups in society
are catered for and made aware of the
accessibility issues
that others face this all-encompassing
approach
has even encouraged the creation of a
local access city award which is awarded
to a business or organization
that has worked with its customers to
improve access for them
for its inclusive and universal
bottom-up approach to accessibility
john shopping wins first prize in the
access city award
2021. congratulations
so representatives
footsetter at bigger and including
understood
on behalf of censorship is disability
rice federation
i feel very honored and privileged to be
a part receiving this award
this is a highly valued acknowledgements
that our ways of working has been
successful
ensure that we are on the right track we
also hope that we can serve as an
inspiration for other cities to use this
method in their work for
diversity and inclusion the key
success factor in our work is that it
originates from persons with first-hand
experience
from their own functional abilities
includes cooperation with the city
representatives of human shipping
we have been able to design and
implement inclusive environment
for example accessible sidewalks
pedestrian crossings and
the right mindset the important topic
needs
constant focus and there is still room
for improvement
also in our city and this award will
serve as a
moral booster for our continuous efforts
thank you
well once again congratulations nick
we've come to an end it's been an
amazing ride how must feel it was a
privilege to to host this event and
i'm more than happy that there's so much
attention for this subject as well
well i i feel privileged as well
congrats to all the winners
thanks to commissioner and all the
participants and of course follow the
award on social media
comment the event on youtube and
facebook let us know what you think
about it
and of course share the info about this
prize with your municipality and
encourage them to apply
for the next edition maybe it's even
going to be my city of rotterdam
gratissiona shopping congratulations to
all the winning cities
in the access city award 2021
thank you for participating and for your
dedication to accessibility
thank you also to all the applicants i
count on all of you to continue to be
leading examples and invest in
accessibility
there is a long road ahead to reach our
union of equality
but i am convinced that together we can
achieve our goals
thank you to all national and eu jurors
for your dedication and for the good
work you have done
i also thank colleagues and the
directorate general for
employment social affairs and inclusion
and our contractors for organizing the
competition
and the ceremony and i thank you again
roger and nick without a doubt i look
forward
to meeting you all in person in brussels
for next year's award ceremony
[Music]
you